♪～
コラボは最初 「はいどうもー」って入るんですよ
はいどうも…
って感じです
はい！どうもー！！
・・・・・・（笑）
こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと
こんにちは！木下ゆうかです！（キラリンッ）
まあ大食いYoutuberといったらまあ
僕ですよね
私！！！
大食いをしたいんですけど
いつも残しちゃうわけでございます
ちゃんと食べますけどね？
うんうん（うなずき）
食べてますけど、
ちょっと今日はね、神の力を借りるということで、
大食い系YouTuberの木下ゆうかさんにお越しいただいて　おります
がんばりま～～す
とりあえず・・・
アイスが、アイスが溶けよる
今回はですね、
マクドナルドのメニューを全種類買ってきました。
サイズのかぶりは全部抜きで、
一応全種類こちらにあります。
迷惑かかるから、ちゃんと予約して頼んでくださいね
１個ずつ紹介していきましょう
（早口で）ビックマック、クォーターパウンドチーズ、ダブルクォーターパウンド、ダブルチーズバーガー
（早口）ベーコンレタスバーガー、チーズバーガー、フィレオフィッシュ、えびフィレオ
てりやきマックバーガー、チキンフィレオハンバーガー、チキンクリスプ、マックダブル
チキンナゲットマックピース
え、違う
チキンマックナゲット５ピース
とんかつマックバーガー、ロコモコバーガー、プチパンケーキ、ハワイアンパンケーキ、スイートコーン、アップルパイ、バーベキューソース、マスタードソース
フライドポテトL、サイドサラダ、コカ・コーラL、ファンタグレープゼロ
はじめ）あ、ここは言っていいですよ
木下）ええ～！？く、クイルk§＃＆*※ΘДΘ％＠・・・
（笑）
全種類！151種類あるんで・・・
木下）　え、さっきだって全部１人で食べるっていう・・・
はじめ）　全部食べますけど～
まだ本気出しちゃダメだと思ってるんで
木下）本気出そうよ！？
木下）怠けるようなこと言わないでください～
はじめ）ごめんなさい
はじめ）　ちゃんとやります！僕も本気出すんで！
木下） 私も本気出すんで！
はじめ） では、さっそく全部食べていきます！
はじめ） じゃあロコモコバーガー・・・
木下） あたしがそれ食べたかったの！
はじめ） ええ～　じゃあジャンケンで
２人）　最初はグー、ジャンケンポン
木下） ロコモコバーガーいただきまーす！
木下） なんでそんな弱そうなやつ・・・
はじめ） えっなんでなんで！じゃあ違うのいきますよ
はじめ） クォーターパウンダー食べます
木下） マジで？すごい
木下） それで終わる　やろ？
はじめ） （笑）終わらな・・・
２人） いただきまーす
木下） んん～！
はじめ） うまい！
（笑）
♪～
木下） 食べ終わりました～
はじめ） 早！
木下） 女の子扱いしないでください
はじめ） おい早く食えよ
木下） いやそっちでしょ！
（笑）
木下） いつまでハンバーガー食べてんの？（笑）
はじめ） いや待ってください！ちゃんと噛んだほうが・・・
木下） そうだね
はじめ） そうそう
♪～
はじめ） こういう人いません？フードファイターに
はじめ）なんか 縦に動いたほうが・・・
木下） あ～！うんうん
はじめ） 消化がはやく・・・横より縦のほうがいいて聞きました
木下） そうだね
木下） まだそんな・・・そんな段階？もう
（笑）
♪～
木下） 完食です
（笑）
木下） なんでそんなOLみたいな食べ方なの？！笑
♪～
はじめ） 飲み物が全部Lサイズってキツイですね
木下） キツイ　しかも氷が入ってないLサイズやけえ、量めっちゃある
はじめ） そうなんすよ
はじめ） かぶってるサイズのやつは、全部1番大きいサイズにしてあります
♪～
はじめ） よっしゃあ・・・Lサイズキツくないですか
はじめ） だってこういうのペットボトル1本分とかですよね
木下） 氷抜いてもらっとるからね、しかも
はじめ） ですよね
木下） Lの氷抜きのやつやけえ、最強に多いやつ。
はじめ）じゃ 少なくともたぶんペットボトル10本分ありますよね
♪～
はじめ）なんて？
木下）おいしい！！
はじめ）おいしいでしたね
木下）なんでにらむの
木下）なにパズドラしたんやけ回復してーや
（笑）
はじめ）まじすか！？
木下）だってドリンクないと食べれんもん
はじめ）えっ、まじすか（驚き
木下）ドリンク　食べれん（笑）
はじめ）えっ、だって、、、
はじめ）２リットルくらい飲んでますよ！？
はじめ）こんなペットボトル飲んでるんですよ
木下）（笑）
はじめ）えー！！！
はじめ）えっ絶対無理ですって
はじめ）絶対それは無理ですってマジで
木下）飲んだもん！！
はじめ）いや無理ですって
はじめ）絶対無理です、、、
ジュースを移動させる
口笛
木下）あれ？？（笑）
木下）私のじゃなかったけど、これ
はじめ）ほんとに止まんないですね
はじめ）これぐらいならね、ということでございます
木下）２個食べたんだナゲット
すごーい（笑）
（二人）（笑）
はじめ）馬鹿にしてるじゃないですか
木下）サラダ食べよう
♪～
はじめ）はい残り　６品でございます
木下）あ、これ
はじめ）７品でございます
あっ、８品でございます
あと８品です
（二人）パチパチ
はじめ）終わりました、、、
木下）おっ！！！
（二人）拍手
木下）すごーい！！
木下）見事、全部マックの全メニュー食べ終わりました。
（拍手）
バイバーイ